welcome to this video it's a 15-minute
game well let's play you fall for a
change against the VD k2 from Spain huh
I had a Spanish player right before that
so was this alien let's see Bishop b5
check is what I recently played here
Chang do that again led to quite
interesting positions Shh antique
can I wonder about the move all is it
see far as it castles i think i think
it's seafoam yeah i actually have played
this line years ago was right a couple
of times when i was still playing 1.e4
on a regular basis but I always played
the sidelines one year for sidelines
like d3 against the French d 3 against
the calc on and so on so not yeah not
the very very air testosterone heavy
repertoire with 1.e4 always d3 stuff and
if you play like that you might as well
play some other opening okay well anyway
we probably get a maraca see structure
black yeah it's um strangely enough not
taking maybe he's really thinking about
quincy form sometimes you can do that
attacking if for ing to i will just
cancel of course but thinking about it
now maybe if I cäcilie takes on key for
but I can still take on the phone hmm ok
I understand maybe he's really
considering 24 and this move orders
maybe m-maybe rare possible maybe why
just castles first then placed you for
any way or queen e 6 could be another
idea
well i played this very quickly default
maybe some move like Queenie 624 is
really a possibility other than that
yeah I don't really a wandering the
understand us his time investment what
does this mean actually he's going to
grab one on my parts but yeah but can I
do I have no way to protect them anyway
it's um it's certainly am compensation
if it takes e4 I have I won't take you
for this is really clearly very risky I
mean even just defy it as a good move
Queenie 45 night somewhere and Queen a
form forces him to to get into a very
awkward Pinter play king d 8 which looks
really ridiculous ok at Quincy for
Quincy form yes so d5
Quincy form I don't know I can also just
play yeah 92 looks it doesn't it doesn't
really speed up my development maybe
night a 30 interesting so it's not
grabbing at all this is indeed
surprising okay but this should be just
pretty a pretty good position let's
quickly just quickly consider
alternatives it's a 15-minute game you
can think a bit yeah but Queenie force
is probably it simple and good let's see
how to continue now the Queen only six
is obviously a really bad piece the only
way for him to get developed is some
with Knight f6 g6 and I think after
Knight f6 Knight c3 g6 I have 95 and
this is very very annoying and
threatening to take on f6 killing his
pawn structure and 97 winning the Queen
you cannot take maybe rook c8 them but
it looks wow really ugly maybe maybe he
can make it work but it's not it's not
comfortable by any means um it's there
also
yeah knight Knight f6 there's also
Bishop g5 as a possible answer night if
a queen e for Bishop f six wins apiece
and Bishop g5 94 rookie one is also i'm
very good for white yeah let's not spend
ages on g 695 should should ensure some
advantage some advantage g 695 rook c8
maybe maybe Bishop g5 then there's a
good booth the ideas we move he cannot
move the night g6 is probably not
playable even
yeah yeah the Sun move some yeah this
move is basically saying okay I know I
burst but i hope to somehow um limit the
damage how to proceed now yeah it's
always it's always quite tempting to
just to just exchange Quincy and get
into a good end game and it's a good end
game no doubt about that three against
two on the queenside and he's got this
download porn but the question is if
maybe keeping the Queen's on this even
better queen bee three for example queen
d three yeah okay let's say queen d3 is
going to play e6 I guess and Bishop e7
yeah why does in good shape but okay
come on this is just this is just a
better end game with without any
particular um compensation I mean
compensation for the for the bad
structure but should be three Ruby one
group c 1 king activation I have all the
simple standard moves and basically
almost playing with an extra porn
maybe can can try to quickly get in Roxy
8th and a 6 b phi of something like that
but I'm talking about rook c8 b3 a 6
preparing b5 trying to make use of the
unprotected position of the night after
I have played b 3 but not clear that
what this really accomplishes e6 Bishop
is reassured before I have night be five
which is strong I'd c7 as a threat at a
three before very good position yeah f3
was designed to coverage it for so that
i can play Bishop e3 without being a
rasp on IG for it protects efore so that
my night is mobile it's a very typical
strengthening roof i have three and now
i'm i'm just playing luke t 1 king f 1 e
2 moves like that and try to of course
move my majority but I can I don't need
to move it quickly I can first improve
my eyepiece coordination and make sure I
have something on the default
Bishop before night b5 is important
yeah the question is should he play and
move like a six and if he plays a six
should i respond night a form could be
could be an idea but I think just just
the rules yeah he actually played it I
can also consider c5 the the immediate
advance I'm not sure about that at all
right a4 b6 less this could be something
or should I really just play rook the
one ok maybe can reply Luke c8 b3 b5
hmm
not sure at some bit spoiled for choice
IAM
maybe this is a good prophylactic move
on Roxy ADA have night a four and I'm
covering in a way i'm covering c4 so you
cannot take it quickly and i also
prepare c5 I'm not sure so this is the
kind of position where you can spend you
can spend really a much time on in a
tournament game because you've got many
attractive looking possibilities and
it's not so easy to decide which one is
really good or is really the best one ok
and now c5 p.m. this is was one ratio we
had Roxy one to get this support so that
he cannot quickly get some play with be
six or something ok so rookie one was
better so that he cannot even castle
yeah it's not the end of the world but I
could have considered it
it's not a big deal but it probably was
more precise
yeah but look at this now I'm getting
here and ce4 okay maybe maybe I can also
be quick here a4 b5 yeah why not
actually okay let's get this going no
reason to to wait any longer the parts
are quick b5 c6 check gets threatening
really quickly
yeah wait not not so quickly
yeah yeah it's certainly not a bad move
but I wasn't I wasn't 100% sure now here
taking five and attending b5 now just be
five right
94 I can take play be 6 m and then c6
yup and now be six and then are
threatening c6 and it should promote
weight doesn't but almost almost
yeah it's still good though Bishop e7 c6
and their promotes and I'm threatening
night d 6 or 9 a-5 and capturing it the
deep on I can always stop with the king
so the so should be okay
yeah this was an important point of this
breakthrough
black resigned yeah he never really
recovered from the problematic opening
if you're not going to take one of the
pawns then Queenie 6 is really 11 takes
yeah the question really is can you take
some of that I mean that this he cannot
take i'm pretty sure just something like
this and always this Queenie for I needs
to play king the eight or something it's
just just terrible so we cannot take you
forward maybe you can take here I
thought night a three would be a would
be an interesting option gaining a move
and this I this is very slow here and
now some some money to get it night be
five maybe queen bee three or something
queen bee three I don't know are taking
and the Queen move with this it's
interesting i'm not not not clear that
it's a it's it's great but this just
just gets into an ugly position where
black is suffering this yeah i even have
that the comp wants to play Queen you on
but ok it is just a better end game
without any any big big arguments about
it eric g one was more precise here just
playing this first that he cannot even
castle it's a bit bit more precise now
and this is quick already be 5c success
is really quick alright thanks for
watching this